the u.s and turkish defense ministers
are meeting today to discuss the
security of kabul's airport
turkish troops are expected to keep
guard over the important airlink in the
wake
of the u.s led coalition's withdrawal
from afghanistan
most u.s forces have already left and
coalition partners such as
germany and the uk have also pulled out
their units
the taliban meanwhile are making
sweeping gains in many parts of the
country
afghan troops have been fleeing from the
militants but authorities vow they'll
retake
all lost territory
joining us from kabul is journalist ali
latifi ndw correspondent dorian jones
who's standing by in istanbul
dorian turkey's relationship with nato
and the u.s has been
strained of late not to mention the huge
security risk of maintaining
foreign troops in afghanistan why would
turkey agree to continue
providing this support in kabul
well i think they see this is a very
important opportunity to remind all of
its western partners that it is a very
important ally but i think
ankara is not planning to have any
military confrontation with taliban in
fact the government has reiterated they
do not intend to add to the 500 or so
turkish military personnel present in
afghanistan they see this
purely as a as a defense operation
insofar as that they will be looking for
some sort of peaceful agreement with the
taliban
they they are they do have very close
contacts with pakistan
and in fact the turks president recep
tayyip erdogan is talking about
pakistani troops being part of the
operation
in the airport and turkey is aware that
pakistan has very close ties to the
taliban
on top of that it's also looking to
qatar another country that turkey has
close ties with and qatar is hosting
taliban officials so if you lose
looking to these key allies to come to
some sort of agreement whereby turkish
soldiers will not be in the firing line
turkey is aware of how dangerous this
operation is but it sees
high diplomatic uh gold to be had from
taking such an operation
and it's working hard to avoid any
military confrontations from its
presence there
is turkey seeking to expand its
influence in afghanistan and
would what would it stand to gain
well undoubtedly turkey has been working
very hard all across central asia
playing the ethnic turkic card in those
countries to build its influence to
build economic and diplomatic ties and
having
a key role in afghanistan will certainly
enhance those efforts
turkey has built very close ties with
afghans afghanistan's neighbor
uzbekistan and it's looking beyond those
countries as well
but i think the key goal for this whole
operation is to repair ties with the
united states
the u.s has a number of issues with
turkey it was poised to give sanctions
against turkey would devastate the
turkish economy
playing this key role which effectively
gives the u.s a get out of jail card
free
from a major diplomatic crisis will see
turkey
reminding washington it's a key ally and
it needs to work with turkey
dorian thanks ali i'll turn to you the
taliban is advancing almost
unopposed what's the feeling there in
government held
areas
um i wouldn't say they're advancing
unopposed you know there is a government
effort to fight back against them there
are people upper
people's uprising movements fighting
back against them and as much as we hear
reports of districts falling to them we
also hear reports of those districts
being regained everything is sort of an
overdrive at the moment um but there is
you know
this fear that if they are able to so
quickly
trade uh hands with districts you know
from
the government to the taliban and back
and forth uh
that what's to keep them from coming to
kabul at this point there's no real
evidence that they could actually
breach all of the security barriers and
actually make it into the city of kabul
but that fear definitely does exist at
the moment for people
will therefore the turkish troops
increase security in the long term
especially given that the taliban has
said that any foreign troops including
turkish ones will be seen as invaders
well the thing is that the turks have
always had
a unique relationship in afghanistan
they've been very close with the
government
they haven't necessarily been
adversarial with the taliban and the way
other
uh troops have been i mean if you look
at the history of the turkish presence
in afghanistan
they've only come under attack once
maybe twice
and the entire time that they've been
here and turkey is trying to be very
pragmatic and smart about the role it's
playing in afghanistan
it seems to want to keep every party in
the country happy
and if you look at the statements that's
come out with recently since the
announcement of the us withdrawal
they keep saying that they can be like
the one true partner for afghanistan
the one country that can work with them
that can provide services
that can really ally with them right ali
latifi in kabul and dorian jones in
istanbul thank you to you both
you